[Music]
so yeah my name is christine van geen
I'm currently the Ontario Director of
the Canadian Taxpayers Federation we
work on issues of lower taxes government
waste and accountability and oddly
enough this is the third time in six
months that I've done a speech or talk
publicly about the issue of free speech
and specifically free speech on campus I
think that this is a defining topic and
mood of 2017 and oddly support for free
speech is increasingly falling along
partisan or ideological lines now CTF we
at the Canadian Taxpayers Federation we
duel exclusively with fiscal and
economic issues and you would think that
that subject
government debt generational debt and
balanced budgets you know you would
think that that's non-controversial but
not so on university campuses our
student group a generation screwed has
been kicked off of campuses headroom
space denied and we were even told by
one University Student Union that we may
need to change our name generation
screwed because screwed is oppressive so
while we may not have encountered the
kind of blowback that some of some of
the speakers today will have received
from universities it just goes to show
you how little it takes to trigger
university administrators and students
on campuses and just how restrictive and
ham-fisted they can work at how they can
act when restricting speech so with that
I will introduce our speakers our first
panelist is GAD sad he's the professor
of marketing at Concordia University
Montreal Canada he's the holder of the
Concordia University Research Chair in
evolutionary behavioral science and the
Darwinian consumption sorry
he is also quote note white quite well
known for his popular YouTube channel
the sad truth
a channel that has garnered over four
million views yeah so everyone please
welcome dad Saad our second panelist is
they're not sitting in the right order
but I'll introduce is the order in which
they will present if it's John carpe on
the far end he's the president of the
Justice Center for constitutional
freedoms an organization that he founded
to defend the constitutional freedoms of
Canadians through litigation and
education he has a BA in political
science at Laval University in Quebec
City and a law degree from the
University of Calgary so please welcome
John carpe and our third panelist is
Jordan Peterson seated in the middle
he's a psychology professor at the
University of Toronto and a clinical
psychologist with two main areas of
study the psychology of belief including
religion mythology and political
ideology and the assessment and
improvement of personality including the
prediction of creativity academic and
industrial performance so everyone
please welcome Jordan Peterson
and we're going to begin with remarks
from mr. sod all right so apparently a
food restaurant er here in Ottawa cause
me some food poisoning so even the
restauranteurs are trying to stifle my
famous speech because I almost didn't
make it to the session so what are some
strategies for stifling opposing
opinions if you live in a dictatorship
then of course you just kill the
intellectuals those who oppose you you
get rid of them if you are unable to
implement such a strategy then you
perhaps have some hate speech laws or
some campus speech codes and of course
what flows from that is the third way to
stifle people is to create an
environment that is sufficiently ominous
that people engage in self-censorship
this picture right here is worth a
thousand words
it basically says we condemn freedom of
speech that hurts other people's
feelings what I'm going to do for the
rest of today's lecture is simply read
to you first-person accounts of emails
that I receive I receive these in their
innumerable how many I receive where for
either students professors parents are
writing to me to document the stuff that
they are facing on campuses and the best
way to actually show you this is to just
read a bunch of them so bear with me as
I actually go through about seven or
eight of these the clock by the way is
not working so I don't know how much
time we have but I'll assume we're okay
so here is a student testimony example
one I'm a 47 year old white male who
because of an injury made a choice to
return to school sadly it looks like my
path through university is going to be
interrupted and the first year to
maintain full-time status I'm forced to
take another social justice black lives
matter course the challenges students
are not allowed to challenge or question
the course content because that's
considered disrespectful and may disrupt
someone's safe space I believe I am a
respectful student with good attendance
and whose marks average in the mid-80s
that said after a few weeks of the
one-sided syllabus I'm considering
dropping out of the program and leaving
school and
early this leftist academic world is a
little too much for me
testimony to today we had a panel
discussion on the Quebec City shooting
with two historians and two sociologists
where I was told with solemn moral
righteous time that there is no such
thing as good and bad immigrants my
heart was racing and my teeth were
clenched that's great and grinding
listening to this finally despite my
heart beating out of my chest I asked a
question how do you the panel interpret
Charlie Hebdo the Danish cartoon Isis
Salman Rushdie and the Babylon shootings
the denial of individual responsibility
and complete disregard for any value
based interpretation was off the table I
think I screwed myself because I'm
pretty sure my professor is let's say
quite suspicious of me now because this
person aired his opinion he knows that
he's in trouble I just feel really alone
but the thought of restoring strength
tolerance and diversity of thought to
the University really keeps me going
today just really proved to me them up
against and how alone I am what can I do
I'm reaching out to you in the hopes
that the Godfather
that's yours truly would be able to help
direct by future research projects since
most professors and required courses I
have to take seem to be run by social
justice warriors feigning
intellectualism the reason I'm
contacting you is because as an honors
cognitive student part of my
requirements is to complete 12 credits
worth of individual research however
because of purely political reasons I'm
apparently a violent misogynist racist
Trump supporter I have not only lost my
job at a prestigious Behavioral
Neuroscience laboratory I hid the
identity at yyy but my name has been
removed from the publication on research
I personally conducted and the lead
researcher told me that he would never
work with me again this is not North
Korea this is Canada this is us help I'm
a fourth year student in a five year
teaching program I'll be heading to yyy
next year from my one year of Teachers
College only recently have I realized
the radical left-wing messages embedded
in virtually all of my
classes and I know that it will only get
worse at the school in question what can
I do about this how do I stand up for
the truth without risking my career as
an elementary school teacher thank you
let's move on to some faculty those were
all students
I very much appreciate your courage to
fight the cancer that is taking over
American academia people like me feel
cheated and their attempt to pursue a
tenure-track career
it only takes a glimpse to the job
offerings that the Modern Language
Association publishes each year to
understand what is expected from recent
graduates like me it is political
activism and I refuse to mix that with
my academic interests I will save you my
long stories of dealing and suffering
career-wise from politically correct
nonsense from the directions of feminism
gender ideology trans extremism and
Islamophobia I am trying to keep a lid
on things for now as my wife is very as
a very promising academic but hasn't
secured a position yet I know that if I
started voicing my thoughts and
arguments on social media she'd be
completely shut out of the Academy if
she does secure a tenure-track spot I'm
off to the races and you and others
would see diamond I like to take notice
of seriously I'm more than happy to
transition out of philosophy at this
point which has become a virtue
signalling competition as a fellow
professor who has been frustrated by the
discourse within academia on issues such
as political correctness moral
relativism and social justice I'd like
to thank you for speaking up the way you
have a bent from within academia while
my training and research has further
removed from social issues than yours I
have nevertheless been frustrated by the
conformism and groupthink I see and here
around me I see otherwise very
reasonable and capable people abandoning
reason and cowing to the narrative of
the regressive left on many social
issues these are all things which I
would like to get involved in once the
10 year decision is behind me about one
year to go as upsetting as it is one
fears expressing unpopular social ideas
prior to tenure in the meantime please
keep fighting the good fight for freedom
of speech and against thought policing
and orthodoxy almost done I won't read
this whole one but basically this person
writes to me thanking me for my
conversation with sam harris
agreeing with some of the issues that I
raised regarding some you know issues
dealing with Islam but then look at the
bottom he says if you decide to mention
this information in your videos I would
ask that you do so without mentioning my
name I do not have tenure yet this is
from a this is the last testimony and
then I'll wrap up this is from a parent
of a high school student I recently
received an email from my son's school
district that they are going to be
screening a film called I'm not racist
Am I as an in school field trip at the
end of January for high school students
I did some preliminary research on this
and I'm absolutely appalled at the
content of the movie based on the
descriptions the trailer and additional
material surrounding it it appears to be
a feature-length film pushing the
agendas of white privilege institutional
racism and white people are the problem
it scares me beyond belief that they are
attempting to force these ideas on
developing minds and now of course the
usual request that they be anonymous for
reference my son is a junior at xxx I
have included the original email as well
as the PDF of the communication that was
sent out if it is something you feel you
should you should be shared with others
I only ask that you keep identifiable
information for my son or myself out for
our safety
this is not North Korea for his safety
I'm sure you understand so to conclude
freedom of speech is everything and I
should know I come from the Middle East
I escaped that which you don't want to
have replicated here in Canada so no
more language police no more thought
police
no more echo chambers that shun
intellectual diversity
no more identity politics no more
culture of offense and the ethos of
Perpetual victimhood no microaggressions
no trigger warnings no safe spaces and
no cultural appropriation science reason
and logic Trump Trump ideology and
feelings thank you very much
[Applause]
is it okay to to move this away thank
you very much good morning my thanks to
the Manning center Manning conference
for inviting me to speak with you this
morning and it's a it's a great honor to
be on the same panel with dr. Jordan
Petersen and dr. Saad free speech in
Canada is not dead but at Canadian
universities it certainly is on life
support each year the Justice Center
releases the campus Freedom Index most
recently with a new website triple W
campus Freedom Index CA where you can
very easily and quickly look up your own
University and see what letter grade
ABCD F has been assigned to your
University or to your Student Union
based on its policies based on its
practices we're trying to follow dr.
michael walker's great dictum if it
matters measure it so annual campus
Freedom Index measures with objective
criteria the state of free speech at
over 60 Canadian universities the
situation on the whole it's it's very
bad there are far more F's handed out
than there are a letter grades and the
Justice Center has been involved with
over 12 court actions against
universities and Student Union's in four
provinces fortunately we have had some
successes number of years ago the
University of Calgary took it upon
itself to censor a small pro-life group
on campus and threatened the students
with trespassing charges and even with
non academic misconduct charges with
penalties ranging up to expulsion if
they continued to express their pro-life
views on campus
the students continued with their
expression and they were indeed found
guilty of non academic misconduct for
having done so now the penalty was not
expulsion it was a warning but we took
the university to court and in 2014 in
the case of Wilson versus University of
Calgary we got the court ruling setting
aside the University of Calgary's
decision to find the students guilty of
non academic misconduct so that case is
now a precedent that can be used by
students across Canada we also recently
this past summer sued the Brannon
University Student Union which had
banned a campus pro-life Club which of
course is significant because if you
don't have the official club status you
cannot participate in clubs day or book
a table or you cannot on par with the
other clubs rent out a room or hold an
event invite a speaker or host to debate
etc so we sued the Student Union at
Brandon University and before the action
got very far they did settle and the
reinstate of the club so another
positive result
but universities are very clever so
we've got the University of Alberta
which is obviously aware of the
precedent against the University of
Calgary
so rather than censor speech directly
itself with the University does is it
lets the mob censor the expression that
is unpopular so in 2015 the pro-life
group put up a peaceful stationery
display and there's a huge mob of people
came with sheets and towels and banners
and megaphones and swarmed it and
rendered it completely impossible to
carry on any kind of civil conversation
or dialogue or debate now in spite of
the fact that the University of
Alberta's code of student behavior
expressly prohibits interrupting
obstructing or interfering with
university related activities and events
in spite of very clear provisions in the
code of student behavior when this
disruption and obstruction took place
campus secure
stood by and watched and did nothing to
enforce it beyond the university's own
code of conduct the following year 2016
the students went back filled out a form
to have another display in the
university says yes you can you can put
up a display on campus provided that you
pay us a security fee of seventeen
thousand five hundred dollars now of
course if you're if it's the campus gay
pride march or if it's a feminist or
socialist or Aboriginal or
environmentalist expression there's no
security fees required for that but if
your opinion is unpopular or
controversial you're not allowed to
express it on campus unless you pay a
security fee of seventeen thousand five
hundred dollars so we're suing the
University of Alberta and the court in
Edmonton is going to hear our case
coming up in June and it's going to be
hugely as for better or for worse you
can't predict ahead of time if you'll
win or lose but this is going to have a
huge impact on the rule of law because
the message that the University of
Alberta is sending to its own students
and to the whole world is that if you
disagree with somebody else's opinion
you should shut them down and silence
them and that's the message you know and
it's tempting you know for people who
disagree with or perhaps despise or
detest the pro-life viewpoint it's
tempting to you know kind of chuckle
because you know this is being shut down
but it should be obvious to any thinking
person if this is the condone trend
that's going to cut in all directions
and it's not going to be too long before
you're going to see all kinds of views
and eventually even left-wing views
they're going to get shut down by mobs
if this is not fought immediately and
urgently what to do about the situation
I've got five recommendations firstly
exercise your free expression rights
freedom is like a muscle if you don't
exercise your muscles they atrophy and
wither and become weak and useless
conversely if you exercise your muscles
they stay strong and get even stronger
so exercise your
expression rates do not be intimidated
by the name-calling we've all heard it
racist sexist homophobic transphobic
Islamophobic etc etc if you self censor
you are giving ground to the enemies of
freedom and we have to make a commitment
to the idea that it's better to die
standing than to live on your knees a
second point come to the defense of
others whose freedoms are threatened
makes a huge difference especially if
it's somebody that you disagree with the
justice center takes we have taken no
position on we're not pro-choice
we're not pro-life but we're Pro free
speech so we take no position on
abortion as it turns out most of our
clients on university campuses are
pro-life groups
we're also acting for the men's issues
we're in a society which is suing a
Students Union at at Ryerson University
I'm sad to say that in most of these
cases when a pro-life group is getting
censured by the university or by the
Student Union in most cases they get no
help from the campus Christian clubs yet
no help from the campus Jewish campus
Muslim campus conservative clubs and
there they're all alone you can make a
huge difference if you see somebody else
being silenced or treated unfairly when
you speak up it's especially powerful if
you say I don't agree with their
viewpoint at all but they have a right
to speak their opinions in a peaceful
fashion on campus and what you're doing
with your censorship is wrong and that's
very powerful so we need to do more of
that is speak up for others who are
being persecuted thirdly sign our
petition no taxpayer funding for
universities the censor it's high time
that universities were stopped from
perpetrating a fraud on taxpayers which
they do by going to the general public
into the politicians and saying we
believe in academic inquiry we believe
in freedom of speech we believe in frank
honest debate
as a tool for reaching truth and they
get thirteen billion dollars per year
from taxpayers most of it from
provincial governments and then they
take the thirteen billion and turn
around and they don't even honor their
own mission and mandate and that can be
stopped by legislation provincially
provinces simply up to amend the
legislation and say universities are not
getting money I must say uphold free
expression on campus so please sign the
petition there's copies that our justice
center booth and there's also copies in
that in the back of the room fourth
point support the groups that are
defending the free society don't assume
that the organizations out there that
have their booths up that there's a
there's a few billionaires that are all
giving these groups a hundred thousand
dollars a year I know with the Justice
Center and I think it's true for a lot
of the groups out there the majority of
the money that we get that comes in the
form of the $200 $500 $100 donations
that's 60% of our budget so don't don't
leave it to some imaginary wealthy
person but step up to the plate and
support the groups if you're not already
doing so that are defending the free
society last but not least when you
yourself are in a situation where your
fundamental freedoms are being violated
whether it's your freedom of expression
your freedom of conscience and religion
your freedom of association stand your
ground do not be intimidated this is
really where the war is fought freedom
is lost when people cave in and
capitulate on fundamental points of
principle when they shouldn't and I said
earlier it's it's a great honor to be on
the same panel with dr. Jordan Peterson
if more Canadians showed the courage and
fortitude that he is demonstrating on a
daily basis in the face of adversity we
be a lot better country thank you
[Applause]
so I want to recommend a book first to
everyone here it's called explaining
post-modernism and it's by a gentleman
named Steven Hicks and you need to
understand post-modernism because that's
what you're up against and you're up
against it far more than you know or
think and it's a much more
well-developed and pervasive pernicious
nihilistic intellectually attractive
doctrine than has yet come to public
realization it absolutely dominates the
humanities and increasingly the social
sciences in the universities and what's
happening you see someone once said who
unfortunately I can't remember it might
have been Friedrich Nietzsche said that
everybody is the unconscious exponent of
a dead philosopher and fortunately the
postmodern Philosopher's most of them
are dead so that's a good thing but that
doesn't mean that their words aren't
continually being spoken by people who
who are following in their wake let's
say and it's not like any given person
is absolutely possessed saved by the
spirit of post-modernism because often
they're not educated enough to know all
the details about what it is that has
them in their grip but if you get 20 of
them together and they're all 5%
influenced by the post modernist ethos
you basically have the spirit of the mob
that's a mouthpiece for that particular
philosophical doctrine and if you
understand the doctrine then you
understand why things are progressing
the way that they're progressing and so
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
the doctrine because it's not optional
to understand this it's absolutely
crucial to understand this you can't
underestimate the power of ideas and
also the power of words of course
because ideas are expressed in words but
you see the post modernists completely
reject the structure of Western
civilization and I mean completely so I
can give you an example in one term
Jacques Derrida whose head trickster for
the post modernist movement regarded
Western culture let's call it the
patriarchy as fallow go centric okay so
fallow come
from phallus PHA ll oh and so that's the
insistence that what you see in Western
culture is the consequence of a
male-dominated oppressive self-serving
society and we might say well you know
societies do tend to be self-serving and
people in power do tend to act in their
best interests but a tendency is not an
absolute and that's one of the things
that needs to be considered continually
there are no shortage of flaws in the
manner in which we've structured our
society and compared to any hypothetical
utopia it's an absolutely dismal wreck
but compared to the rest of the world
and the plight of other societies
throughout the history of mankind we're
doing pretty damn well and we should be
happy to be living in the society that
we're living in so the first thing that
you might want to note about
post-modernism is that it doesn't have a
shred of gratitude and there's something
topologically wrong with the person who
does that it doesn't have any gratitude
especially when they lived in what so
far is the best of all possible worlds
and so if you're not grateful you're
driven by resentment and resentment is
the both the worst emotion that you can
possibly experience apart from arrogance
resentment arrogance and deceit there is
an evil triad for you and if you're
bitter about everything that's happening
around you despite the fact that you're
bathed in wealth and there's something
absolutely wrong with you you know the
black community in the United States is
the 18th wealthiest community 18th
wealthiest nation on the planet now that
doesn't mean there isn't such a thing as
relative poverty and relative poverty
matters it's an important it's an
important political economic issue and
it's very very difficult to deal with
but absolute wealth matters too and
Western societies have been absolutely
remarkable in their ability to generate
and distribute wealth as you can tell by
just looking around and taking a you
know a brief bit of consideration for
the absolute miracle that even a
building like this represents so you
have to educate yourself about
post-modernism ok so here's what the
post modernists believe they don't
believe in the individual that's the
logos Park Western culture is fel logo
centric logo is logos that's partly the
Christian word but it's also partly the
root word of logic okay they don't
believe in logic they believe that logic
is part of the process by which the
patron
Oracle institutions of the West continue
to dominate and to justify their
dominance they don't believe in dialogue
the root word of dialogue is logos again
they don't believe that people of
goodwill can come to consensus through
the X through the exchange of ideas they
believe that that notion is part of the
philosophical substructure and practices
of the dominant culture so the reason
they don't let people who they don't
agree with speak on campus is because
they don't agree with letting people
speak you see it's not part of the ethos
okay so what else do they believe and
not believe they believe that you since
you don't have an individual identity
your fundamental identity is Group
fostered and that means that you're
basically an exemplar of your race
hence white privilege or you're an
exemplar of your gender or your sex or
your ethnicity or you're an exemplar of
however you can be classified so that
you you are placed in the position of
victim against the oppressor because
that's the game and it's it's a it's a
post Marxist sleight of hand right the
old Marxist notion was that the world
was a battleground between the burgeois
Z and the proletariat and that failed to
have any philosophical or ethical
standing that argument after the working
class actually saw its standard of
living massively elevated as a
consequence of Western corporate
democracy Western free enterprise
democracy and also the end and also as a
consequence of the revelations of
everything terrible that had happened in
every bloody country that ever dared to
make equity and and the Marxist
communist dogma part of their
fundamental structure right and nothing
but murderous nozanne depression and so
by the 1970s it was evident that that
game was up the postmark the post
modernist Marxist just barely basically
pulled a sleight of hand and said okay
if it's not the poor against the rich
it's the oppressed against the oppressor
will just read of I'd the subpopulations
in ways that make our our bloody
philosophy continuing it's in its in its
movement forward and that's where we're
at now and so for the post modernists
the world is a Hobbesian battleground of
identity groups they do not communicate
with one another
they can't all there is is a struggle
for power and if you're in the predator
group which means you're an oppressor
then you better look out because you're
not exactly welcome not exactly welcome
and neither are your ideas so that's
what you're up against I would say it's
time for conservatives to stop
apologizing for being conservatives no
and you don't apologize to these people
that's a big mistake apology there they
read apology as an admission of guilt
you don't apologize and you don't back
down you young people that are out there
who are University students you need to
take over the student unions you need to
take them back because they're absolute
snake pits and they have been since the
1990s and with regards with regards to
the universities I thought at one point
that the best thing to do would be to
cut their funding by 25% let them fight
amongst themselves for the remnants
because it would force the universities
to decide exactly what's important and
what isn't so I would say the humanities
and much of the social sciences has
turned into a postmodern neo-marxist
playground for radicals the scholarship
is terrible 80% of humanities papers
aren't cited once once and so what that
means is that they write papers for each
other and they sell them to libraries
and that's how the publishers make their
money and no one reads them but the
publishers can print them because the
libraries have to buy them and they're
buying them with your tax money and so
all of you who are sitting here are
funding a postmodern radical neo-marxist
agenda that has its roots in the
university and your tax money is going
towards that and if you want proof of
that you just go online and look at the
websites especially of disciplines like
women's studies which is pathological
right to the core but it's not just
women's studies it's all the ethnic
studies groups
it's anthropology its sociology its
Social Work and most of all its
education and oisi for example in
Ontario is perhaps apart from the
Ontario Human Rights Commission the most
dangerous institution in Canada it
should it should be defunded it's as
simple as that they don't do the
research they purport to do they're not
interested in it at all in education
they're interested in the indoctrination
of people as young as they can as
young as they can get their hands on so
to speak
now we need to figure out our society
needs to figure out how to stop shunting
public tax money to radical left-wing
activists if we were doing that for
radical right-wing activists there would
be an absolute storm but it's happened
incrementally since the 1960s and it
needs to stop
so that's that's partly what the
Conservatives not only conservatives but
also liberals true liberals in the
English sense are up against I mean
what's happened as also as a consequence
of this postmodern neo-marxist
intellectual invasion is that the centre
keeps moving it's moved way to the right
now so if you're a classic liberal
you've become a conservative and so for
all of you who are interested in pretty
pursuing a conservative agenda there's a
lot of classic liberals that you could
be talking to and then finally with
regards to talking to young people you
finally have something to sell to them
you know it's not easy to sell
conservatism to young people because
they want to change things and that's
not what conservatives want to do they
want to maintain things well now you've
got something to sell to young people
you can sell them freedom of speech and
you can tell sell them responsibility
the left is selling them rights you can
sell them responsibility and I can tell
you because I received many letters of
the sort that that God was talking about
young people are absolutely starving for
someone to provide them with the sense
of responsibility and say look here's
something worth living for man
you know you can find meaning in life
with freedom but freedom freedom is a
chaotic sort of meaning right and
freedom isn't the sort of thing that
makes people happy it's the sort of
thing that makes people trouble some
trouble because freedom expands your
your series of choices and that makes
you nervous and uncertain so but
responsibility is another not to say
that that's a bad thing it's a good
thing but it requires that you that you
shoulder the responsibility of the
freedom but responsibility per se is
what gives your life meaning genuine
meaning in the face of suffering and you
and young people is really they're
starving for that I've been teaching
young people for thirty years and mostly
what I've been teaching them about is
responsibility it's like your heirs to a
great tradition it's not perfect
obviously but comparatively there's
nothing else like it that's ever been
produced and it's it represents a tiny
minority of human qualities most of
which are run by murderous antisocial
psychopathic thugs and that's seriously
and so what kind of alternative is that
we've got this beacon of freedom and
wealth in the West that works although
it doesn't work perfectly and one of the
one of the responsibilities of young
people is to find out what's at the core
of that the great great core of that the
paramount the paramount importance of
the individual and the divinity of
speech man not some to sell its what our
whole culture is predicated on
all right well I should stop there so
thank you very much for the invitation
so thank you very much to all of our
speakers really insightful comments I'm
just going to lead a bit a 20 minute
discussion 15 minute discussion and my
first question is the direction in which
we're going so there was a poll that was
published by The Economist and I think
two issues ago that showed the support
among young people for different sets of
rights in different countries across the
world and they found that support for
the expansion of rights that are
considered rights for historically
marginalized groups so the right for
women's equality right to same-sex
marriage Rachael bortion things like
that even in countries where those
rights are not enshrined in law have
incredible amounts of support among
young people the only exception is the
right to free speech particularly the
right to speech that may be perceived as
offensive to minority groups in that
category countries like Britain Germany
and Canada the support among young
people for that right is under 50% so
right now we have receipts we see
censorship self censorship and real
state censorship by people who actually
hold the levers of power in government
and in institutions but when these
people who right now have less than 50
percent support for the right to free
speech are 15 years from now the ones
holding those levers of power where do
you see this going well the the
short-term future is very bleak but I I
always say you just got to keep on
fighting for what is right and
exercising courage and we can't say what
the medium term or long term future is
you know the history is is quite I'm
fixable but the short-term trends are
terrible I think another thing for
people in the audience who are parents
is don't get your kids out of the public
education system and do homeschooling or
private school make that a priority you
know even if you can't afford it figure
out a way because this indoctrination
into these postmodernist or neo-marxist
type ideas it just permeates the whole
curriculum whether it's it's math
science social studies what-have-you
so that's something practical certainly
the the students that are now 18 19 20
it's obvious that in high school they've
never been taught that if there's an
idea that you disagree with while you
come up with reasons why that's wrong
and you try to use facts and logic to
engage in discussion that's a you know
it you get these mobs as you know why I
feel very offended by by what you said I
feel that way and therefore you
shouldn't be allowed to say it well were
they getting that from I mean that
that's coming out of the K to 12
education system yeah you know one of
the things that I try to do is to
convince both colleagues and students
and anybody who's willing to listen to
participate participate in the trench
warfare of ideas many people feel as
though they don't have the necessary
platform the necessary testicular
fortitude to actually battle but then
they see gentlemen like Jordan Peterson
if I may include myself and a few others
who are on the front lines and then they
feel very invigorated so the I think the
the ship can be turned around as long as
people feel sufficiently empowered that
they actually have a voice you could
weigh in simply on your Facebook page
you could weigh in at the bar when
speaking to someone everybody has a
voice and everybody should feel
sufficiently invigorated and the
possibility of lending their voice to
the debate and if we can do that then I
don't think we need to be pessimistic if
we can't convince people to do that then
I think it will be an infinite abyss of
darkness
so you know one way of conceptualizing
yourself is that you're one speck of
dust among seven billion and when you
conceptualize yourself that way you
might think well what difference does it
make what I say or do and that's
actually quite convenient for you
because if it doesn't matter what you
say her due then you don't have any
responsibility and you can do whatever
you want the price you pay for that is a
bit of nihilism but if you don't have to
shoulder any responsibility that's a
small price to pay another that's the
underground motivation for nihilism but
the other way of looking at it and this
is actually the accurate way of looking
at it is that you're in a network you're
a node in a network and so you can do a
little bit of arithmetic very rapidly
and just figure out how powerful you are
you know a thousand people you're going
to know more than that over the course
of your life but let's say a thousand
for the sake of argument for now they
know a thousand people that means that
you're one person away from a million
people and two persons away from a
billion people and you're the center of
that network and now the way networks
work is that information propagates in a
networked manner so don't underestimate
the power of your speech now you know
Western cultures FAL logo centric let's
say it okay so we'll say yeah that's
just fine that's exactly what it is it's
predicated on the idea of the logos that
the logos is the sacred element of
Western culture and what does that mean
it means that your capacity for speech
is divine it's the thing that generates
order from chaos and then sometimes
turns pathological order into chaos when
it has to don't underestimate the power
of truth there's nothing more powerful
now in order to speak what you might
regard as the truth you have to let go
of the outcome you have to think all
right I'm going to say what I think
stupid as I am bias as I am ignorant as
I am I'm going to state what I think as
clearly as I can and I'm going to live
with the consequences no matter what
they are now the reason you think that
that's an element of faith the idea is
that nothing brings a better world into
being than the stated truth now you
might have to pay a price for that but
that's fine you're going to pay a price
for every bloody thing you do and
everything you don't do
don't get to choose to not pay a price
you get to choose which poison you're
going to take that's if so if you're
going to stand up for something stand up
for your truth it'll it'll shape you
because people will respond an object
and tell you why you're a fool and a
biased and why you're ignorant and
then if you listen to them you'll be
just that let much less like that the
next time you say something if you do
that for five years you'll be so damn
tough and articulate and able to
communicate and withstand pressure that
you won't even recognize yourself and
then you'll be a force to contend with
and you don't get to wait until because
I get letters like GAD sod gets all the
time to from faculty members in
particular and they say well you know
when I get tenure it's like then they
think well when I'm an associate
professor and then they think well when
I'm a full professor it's like if you're
a professor already you're like the most
protected person in the history of the
planet you know and you need well okay
but what one of the things that that
indicates is that it's almost impossible
to provide people with enough protection
so that they feel safe to speak okay so
we'll address that directly it is not
safe to speak and it never will be but
the other thing you got to keep in mind
is that it's even less safe not to speak
right it's a balance of risks it's like
you want to you want to pay the price
for being who you are and stating your
mode of being in the world or do you
want to pay in the price for being a
bloody serf a one that's enslaved him or
herself well that's a major price man
that thing unfolds over decades and
you'll just be a miserable worm at the
end of about 20 years of that right no
self-respect no power no ability to
voice your opinions nothing left but
resentment because everyone's against
you because of course you've never stood
up for yourself it's like say what you
think carefully pay attention to your
words the prices it's a price you want
to pay if you are willing to believe
that truth is the cornerstone of society
and in the most real sense if you're if
you if you're willing to take that leap
then tell the truth and see what happens
and nothing better could possibly happen
to you
you'll be ups and downs or nobody
push back and it'll be controversy and
all of that but it doesn't matter the
truth is what makes the world the truth
is what redeems the world from hell and
that's the truth and we saw plenty of
Hell for the last hundred years you know
and we haven't learned a bloody thing
from it it's like wake up tell the truth
tell the truth or at least don't lie if
that's a start and you got to understand
that's a risk but I will write one more
brief thing to say about that um so you
know I said what I had to say back in
September and I'm sure that I could have
done it better and many people have told
me how I could have done it better
although it didn't mean they would
actually do it but
[Applause]
and you know my job was at risk serious
risk for about two months and it
destabilized my family being very brains
about this so like thumbs up to their
mandate
they've just stood by but up here's the
optimistic news the university has left
me alone completely I shook hands with
the Dean two weeks ago we're on friendly
terms they don't want this to go any
farther than it has already the students
were tremendously welcoming when I get
back to teach in January I haven't had a
single negative incident at the
University and I've received thousands
of letters from people all over the
world all of which have been in support
I've received two negative letters
that's if - so the people people have an
inchoate longing to have the sort of
thing that we're talking about
articulated and so don't be thinking
you're alone it's just that people can't
talk they're afraid to talk or they
don't know what to say and those are
real problems so if you're reasonably
articulate like start talking and
sharpen yourself up I mean the enemy is
a cloud there are cloud of naps they're
only courageous in groups there are only
courageous in mobs if you stand your
ground and don't apologize and
articulate things properly they'll
disperse around you like they're not
even there so most of it's illusion so
there will be be afraid but be afraid of
the right thing and the right thing you
should be afraid of is not saying what
you say because that's the same as not
being and here you are suffering and
away you might as well be at the same
time at least then there's something to
you so
so one of the other things I wanted to
ask your opinion about is what role do
provocateurs play in the debate over
free speech so the example of the dais
is obviously Milan innopolis are these
champions of free speech or do they
undermine public support for the right
or are they simply self-interested
people who are hijacking a right in
order to promote themselves and their
own interests and obviously is this a
new phenomenon or is it something that
is is is age-old there all of those Mylo
is a classic example he's an amazing
person I mean he's he's a contradiction
he's a walking contradiction you can't
pin that guy down right like what is he
half Jewish half English gay ah temple
provocateur Catholic who's really who
loves black guys and who who who is it
who appeals to American Republicans it's
like what are you going to say about
something somebody like that it's like
he's a he's a trickster figure
archetypically speaking you know and
he's he's a provocateur and a comedian
and the funny thing about comedians
they're like gestures in the king's
court the jester was the only person who
could tell the truth because he was
beneath contempt and that's the role
that comedians and provocateurs play
they're poking they're poking and
laughing and making fun and you know
Milo Christ even dresses like a what do
you call those a Harlequin you know he's
a trickster and trickster figures emerge
in times of crisis and they point out
what no one wants to see and they say
things that no one will say and you can
say all the terrible things about him he
is a provocateur he's an egomaniac he's
a he I don't think he's narcissistic but
because he has the real capacity for
self-reflection but and he's brave as
can be I mean and he's unstoppable on
his feet he just amazes me I've never
seen anyone ever I don't think and I've
met some pretty damn smart people I've
never seen anyone who can take on an
onslaught of criticism and reverse it
like he can it's bloody amazing but he
has all those things he described but
you know the times call for
thus the speakers and we called forth
Milo and yes yeah well in that tells you
what our farms are so Milo's been on my
show and he's supposed to come again
soon
he said he's exactly the things that
Jordan said at times he he has an
ability to depart from truth he was
speaking right
so for example when he says things like
there is no such thing as lesbians well
I appreciate his provocative nature but
then it'd be nice to stay closer to the
truth but to the extent that he is
getting a lot of young people engaged
probably more than Jordan and I could
you know in our lifetimes a lot of
people are associating to him and so his
central message is really important so
even if once in a while he makes a
departure from truth I'll grant him that
because his greater his own that is
quite important so I certainly support
him I just add that it's the so called
extreme speech that pushes the envelope
and that ends up in the long run being
fundamentally transformative once the
the top question asked always is it true
or to what extent is it true or why is
it not true truth is always the thing to
to think about we should never be
concerned with whether something is
quote extreme or not because that
changes from year to year from decade to
decade I mean you think you know in 1969
it would have been extreme to advocate
for gay marriage that would have been an
extreme position with less than 1%
support and today in many quarters is
considered extreme to say that gay
marriage is a bad thing
so extremism changes from from year to
year decade to decade month to month it
should never be a criteria for your
speed is it extreme or not that's not
the right question the question is it
true or false is it right or wrong those
are the questions to ask okay really
quickly one final question part of the
debate that we have when we talk about
free speech is in universities is is a
university a public institution or is it
an institution of higher learning
no one would dispute that the Manning
Center is free to invite disinvite or
not invite anyone that they want to come
to this conference to learn and to train
but because universities are recipients
of large amounts of tax dollars are they
more a public institution that is
required to provide a bigger forum for
sweet free speech and where do you draw
that line when organizations that
receive large amounts of charitable tax
benefits are freer to disinvite or not
invite or not host you don't have to
give a platform to some of whose speech
you disagree with but when do you when
you're the recipient of public monies I
think in the current context with with
the universities receiving thirteen
billion dollars a year from taxpayers in
that particular context I think that
they don't have the right to behave as a
private institution like Trinity Western
University which gets no government
funding that's very different if Turney
Western University said we're going to
ban the expression of atheism or Islam
on campus say well it's a private
institution as long as they're upfront
about that that when you go there you
know that pro-islamic or Pro atheist
speech is outlawed and you still choose
to go to that university but ironically
what I've heard from people currently
and in the past that are attending
Trinity they do have Muslims and
atheists and gay people there and it is
a healthy vigorous intellectual climate
but in response to the question if your
private institution you can invite or
not invite you can do whatever you want
but for the universities because they're
holding themselves out as supposedly in
favor of academic inquiry and free
expression they should be required to
honor that commitment that they've made
to to taxpayers
you